Os sucos de uva integrais, mesmo em
garrafas de vidro escuras de
supermercado, são saudáveis? Bem, sabe
aquela sensação de estar fazendo a coisa
certa quando você coloca num carrinho do
supermercado aquele suco de uva
integral, vidro escuro, achando que está
levando saúde pura pra casa? Pois é,
preciso te contar umas verdades que vão
fazer você repensar essa escolha. Não é
que seja tudo ruim, mas também não é
essa maravilha toda que a gente imagina.
OK? Olha só, vamos começar pelo básico.
Quando você lê integral no rótulo, o
cérebro já faz aquela associação
automática com saúde. É tipo quando a
gente vê light ou zero, parece que tá
tudo certo. Mas esa aí que a história
não é bem assim.
O suco integral realmente é feito com a
uva inteira, casca, polpa, às vezes até
a semente. Isso é bacana porque tem o
resveratrol, aquele antioxidante
poderoso que todo mundo fala, mas tem
uns pormenores que fazem toda a
diferença. Primeiro vamos falar daquele
elefante na sala, o açúcar. Mesmo sendo
o açúcar natural da fruta, a frutose, um
copinho de 200 ml pode ter até 30 g de
açúcar. Isso é mais ou menos duas
colheres de sopa cheias, meu amigo. E
olha que interessante, quando você come
uma uva, mastiga devagar, tem as fibras
que retardam a absorção. Mas no suco é
um tsunami de açúcar chegando no seu
sangue de uma vez só. É como se o seu
pâncreas levasse um susto e tivesse que
trabalhar em dobro para dar conta da
insulina. E tem mais, aquela garrafa
bonita de vidro escuro passou por um
processo chamado pausterização. Sabe o
que que é isso? Eles aquecem o suco a
85ºC
e depois dão um choque térmico,
esfriando rapidinho para 40º. É tipo dar
um banho quente e depois um gelado mata
tudo. Inclusive boa parte das vitaminas
termosensíveis e todas aquelas enzimas
maravilhosas que ajudam na digestão. O
que que sobra? Os minerais que são mais
resistentes e parte dos antioxidantes.
Mas cadê a vitamina C? Foi pro espaço.
Agora deixa eu te contar uma coisa que
poucos sabem. Muitos desses sucos
integrais de supermercado tem uns
truques na manga. Alguns são
reconstituídos a partir de concentrados.
É como se pegassem um suco desidratado e
adicionassem a água de novo. Outros
levam conservantes que nem aparecem
direito no rótulo. E tem aqueles que
usam enzimas industriais durante o
processo para clarificar o suco e deixar
ele mais bonito na prateleira. Natural
que é bom, nada. E sabe o que pior?
Aquela acidez característica do suco de
uva pode ser um problemão para pessoas
que já têm alguma sensibilidade por
algum problema na mucosa do estômago.
Então, pode irritar o estômago de
algumas pessoas, principalmente se você
tomar de manhã cedo e tiver essa
barreira danificada. Eu já vi paciente
meu que achava que estava se cuidando,
tomando suco de uva todo dia e não
entendia porque que a zia não melhorava.
Mas calma, não precisa jogar todas as
garrafas fora. Se você gosta mesmo do
suco, tem umas estratégias espertas.
Primeira coisa, dilua, metade de suco,
metade água. Você ainda pega os
antioxidantes, mas reduz pela metade a
bomba de açúcar. Segundo, tome junto com
uma refeição que tenha proteína e
gordura boa. Isso ajuda a retardar a
absorção do açúcar. terceiro, limite a
um copinho pequeno por dia, no máximo.
Agora, se você quer o melhor dos mundos,
deixa eu te dar uma dica de ouro. Faça o
suco em casa, mas não no liquidificador
comum. Usa centrífuga ou melhor ainda um
slow juicer, aqueles que espremem
devagar e não esquentam. Aí sim você
preserva as enzimas e vitaminas. E sabe
o que melhor ainda? Como a uva, isso
mesmo, a fruta inteira. com casca, com
as fibras, mastigando devagar, é a
natureza do jeito que ela foi feita para
ser consumida. E tem uma alternativa que
quase ninguém conhece, o mosto de uva é
o suco fresquinho, sem pasterizar, que
alguns produtores locais fazem. Tem que
consumir rápido em uns três dias, mas aí
sim você tem todos os benefícios sem os
malefícios do processamento industrial.
Só que não acha no supermercado, tem que
procurar em feiras orgânicas ou direto
com os produtores de uva. Olha, no final
das contas, a questão não é demonizar o
suco de uva integral, ele tem sim os
seus benefícios. Tem os polifenóis, o
resveratrol, alguns minerais, mas também
não é essa porção mágica de saúde que a
indústria quer que a gente acredite. É
um produto processado com alta
concentração de açúcar, que perdeu boa
parte dos nutrientes no caminho entre a
videira e a sua mesa. Então, da próxima
vez que você estiver lá no corredor
supermercado, olhando pr aquelas
garrafas de vidro escuro, lembre-se, o
market é bonito, a embalagem é charmosa,
mas a realidade nutricional é bem mais
complexa. Se quiser mesmo os benefícios
da uva, coma a fruta preferencialmente.
Se quiser o prazer do suco, tome com
moderação, tome com consciência. E se
quiser uma bebida realmente saudável pro
dia a dia, água, meu amigo, água.
continua sendo imbatível.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
Doutor, além do se envolva. Ah.